hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
adding dimensions to multiplex molecular
imaging
i am jen woods of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by leica microsystems
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site at
ligomicrosystems.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr scott fraser
elizabeth garrett chair of convergent
bioscience
provost professor departments of
molecular and computational biology
of biomedical engineering for a complete
biography on our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr fraser you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you for including me today in
the program
i'm very excited to tell you about what
we've been doing in the lab
to try to add dimensions to the
multiplex imaging we do mostly of live
specimens
these three examples are things that
i'll draw on a bit today
and uh try to amplify our ability to
follow
live multiplex images uh
in uh living specimens
so i'll start by saying that one of our
goals is to translate
our work and so we take the funding that
we've been able to obtain from some very
forward-looking foundations
and federal agencies and
have converted that through some patents
through caltech
and usc and the alfred mann institute
into a number of different corporate
relationships
and none of the work that i'm uh that
i'm going to present is really
conflicted today but i just
think it's wise to start out by
disclosing all the possibilities
okay so our goal in the lab
in the translational imaging center has
been to try to
do systems-level analyses in
complex systems like developing embryos
and this 21-hour embryo that you see
in the upper right part of the screen is
the zebrafish embryo
it's gone from an egg to an animal that
has a beating heart
and starting to make important neural
connections in its brain
in less than a day so embryos
are ideal for systems level questions
because they're somewhat choreographed
and things happen in a small enough size
and small
and fast enough to use imaging as a way
of addressing it
now most people recently have been doing
single cell analyses and these single
cell analyses are very powerful
they can tell us about the transcriptome
or the proteome inside of the cells
but most of these analyses involve
taking the cells
out of their normal context and when
they're out of the kind of normal
context
we of course don't see their normal
neighbors we don't see
the context in which they're
sitting and we also don't know what
happens next or what happened before the
dynamics are
really lost so one of the
issues is that these analyses show huge
levels of heterogeneity and variability
which we have to try to make sense of
what we've been trying to do is to do an
imaging analysis
or multiplexed living imaging
that really allows us to do an embodied
analysis of those cells
so now the dynamics and the variance
becomes really our signal rather than
our
the noise that we have to explain away
and of course this is going to require
tools that are tailored to this task
so what i'm going to do today is try to
draw on a few different stories in the
lab to give you a feeling for the ways
that we're trying to do this
and some of these will be in fixed
preparations but most of them will be in
living animals where we can follow the
dynamics over time
so i'll return to this slide at the end
but i wanted to start by just saying
that the team that's made this
possible has been just a powerhouse
so i'm going to start by talking a
little bit about the ways that we look
at gene expression
and almost everybody in biology has done
some sort of nc2
hybridization to look at where rnas are
expressed
and almost everybody uses an
enzyme-based
approach to get enough signal above the
background
you can see in the left there's an
embryo with a
domains that are labeled red those that
red
is a reaction product that an enzyme is
laid down
because the appreciable background of a
whole mounted
zebrafish embryo that's shown in gray in
that image
is high enough that if we just use the
direct fluorochrome to label the
individual mrna by using an antisense
probe
the signal would be lost in the noise so
typically an
enzyme is directly or indirectly
conjugated to that antisense probe
and then a chromogen is used to create a
reaction product that can be
seen that amplifies the signal above the
noise
the good thing about it is that it works
the
challenge is to multiplex with it and to
get out the sort of quantitative data
that we're used to
for ins for analyses say of single cell
rna sequencing
because of the um because of the
non-linearity
of the chemistry so it's not really
possible for us
often to see the difference between
subtle
changes in expression because the amount
of time
really alters the way that things
develop
so if i look in the left hand side of
this slide you can see the normal rna
seq sort of approach where here a few
dozen cells are looked at
for a number of dozen of genes and the
code in color tells us what its
expression level is
to the left is the problem we have with
normal and c2 analyses
where this is the same gene pex2 at the
same stage of development
in the same strain of mouse and in fact
in the same paper
and depending on how long the
reaction was allowed to go with the
chromosome
you can see that the patterns can be
quite enough quite a bit different
what we wanted to do is to build
something that would let us
do this in a quantitative fashion and
luckily at caltech where we were at the
time
there were people working on engineering
dna
interactions and the one that we decided
to exploit is called the hybridization
chain reaction
that and we figured that that would
allow us to do quantitative in c2s
i'll show you just a little bit about
that here
it's based around these two hairpins and
these hairpins
are actually somewhat complementary to
one another they would really
like to bind to one another but they're
trapped in this metastable state where
the two
halves of the of the hairpin are uh
are bound to one another and so
they will sit there very nicely even
though they'd like to be binding to one
another because they'd have to open up
and bind one another in solution before
they found themselves and that's very
unlikely
the only thing that breaks that sort of
situation
is if an initiator sequence is present
and the initiator which you can see is
the little squiggle at the bottom
is has a sequence that's designated as a
star b
star that means it's complementary to
the a that's in the toe hold for hairpin
one
and so if it binds to that toe hold now
it can make base pairing to the other
half of the
of the hairpin displacing it doing a
strand displacement
that opens up that hairpin and it
reveals
c star b star which happens to be the
initiator for the other
hairpin and so what we end up with now
is something that regenerates a star b
star and that can grow explosively it
grows explicitly to about a 200 mirror
and we can see that simply in gels here
where
we're running hair pins through an
electrophoretic gel
if the hairpins remain as individual
hairpins they run to the bottom of the
gel on the electric
field and i've got this gel with four
different pairs of hairpins labeled with
different dyes
the star in the picture to the left
represents
dye molecules and you can see that they
migrate down
and the at the bottom of the gel even if
i add
a blender extract of a whole zebrafish
so there's a lot of rnas around and it
doesn't cause the amplification
if instead i add initiator 1 you can see
that blue disappears from the
band at the bottom and appears up above
and it's about a 200 hairpins that have
assembled to give that band
if i add initiator 3 that's the
initiator for the green
hairpins and you can see that green
disappears from the bottom
and it appears again as a 200 mer uh
at the top so this gives us a chance
to give us ourselves a defined
amplification
the initiator gets turned into about 200
dye molecules
to make this into an nc2 hybridization
approach
we make an antisense probe this
antisense
probe hybridizes to the
uh in to the rna that's in the specimen
and it has initiator sequence hanging
off of it so when the hairpins are added
they amplify they amplify
in a way that the rna
is tagged not by one dye molecule
but by 200 per initiator what this
allows us to do
is to use small reagents that assemble
in c2 and therefore can penetrate well
throughout specimens
so we find that the reaction product
amount is proportional to the amount of
rna is that's there
independent of whether it's near the
surface or deep within
we also find nice linear gain which
means that unlike conventional in c2s
where dim things are often lost you can
see the
nascent transcripts that are being
generated in the individual nuclei
are lost in the conventional nc2
on the right if we look at the hcr just
below that
you can see that the dots in the nuclei
capture the
dim relatively dim and
decent transcripts that are in the
nuclei
a few years ago because trivetti worked
on
characterizing the linearity of this
technique and one of the approaches he
used is by
taking the same rna with a couple
different colors so we could compare it
and two important things are shown in
this plot one is that the dimmest
signal is above zero so it's easy to
tell signal from
noise as you can see in the pictures you
don't see that
indeterminate gray in the background
anymore because the
signal has been amplified above that
noise
the other thing you can see is that we
get a nice uh slope of
one where the data clusters very nicely
so it means that we've got a way of
linearly recognizing the rna
able to see even low levels because the
zero is
clearly at above zero and um
and we very happy with it in fact the
quality of the signal is good to just
a few percent well better than five
percent
now one thing that i'll come keep on
coming up today
is that you know biological imaging
really has no free lunches and we're
always trying to trade off photo
damage against speed against resolution
and how deep we're going in the specimen
and so one of our images and any
one of our limitations in any imaging
study then
is to figure out how to get enough
signal per unit time that we can
image more quickly and so one of the
ways that we've been trying to do
this is to add a system
to the hcr in this case we call it muse
it's
been done by a couple of my senior
colleagues in the lab
and this allows us to get another a
couple orders of magnitude and gain so
now what we're doing
is doing the same amplification but
adding to it another round of
linear amplification this gives us the
ability
to put that initiator sequence on
antibodies for example shown on the left
top or on rnas shown in the right top
or even in advanced sort of things like
site off labels so we could do
imaging mass spec as shown at the bottom
so this has allowed us then to put
different initiators on
different uh antibodies of the same
isotypes in this case it's four of four
plaques with
all rabbit antibodies to the left or to
put
five different initiators on five
different rna molecules you can see the
individual
dots that represent the individual
messages and if we blew this up you'd
see that they're
very good about being orthogonal
orthogonal to one another
that is that the the dyes
are very localized to their own rna and
don't cross-react
or we can do for example in this case a
five-plex where
uh we're doing in c2 hybridization for
three rnas plus
immunofluorescence so this technique
gives us a little bit more signal and
lets us go
faster now that's good news it means
that we've got a technique where i can
do
you know half dozen plex at least
langkai at caltech has carried these
sorts of approaches
in serial staining uh to
give him uh you know hundreds to
thousands of different genes
we can look at something like a mouse
embryo shown here with multiple
different genes
in a way that the staining is
independent of how long the animal
stained for
and how long it sat in the fridge so in
this case it sat for a month or two in
the fridge before it was
imaged and so this gives you a chance to
do quantitative and situ's
without having to worry about how to
compare the results
that's the good news now the not so good
news is that that was five
giga voxels of confocal imaging
and that means that we've got a a lot of
imaging time in fact that was 10 hours
of imaging to collect this
mosaic image stack of four by six
image stacks and in fact you can see
just a hair if you've got
sharp eyes of where the image was
scanned twice
where there's a little bit of extra
bleaching and so
this limits our ability to be
quantitative and it also limits the time
and of course what we'd like to do is
image a much
higher power to look at the individual
dots i showed you before
for the muse reaction product for doing
hcr
muse or rna scope or stellaris or any of
the other fluorescence and c2 techniques
this would have to be much slower so
that 10 hours would be an impractical
amount of time
if we needed to go at high power
so that's one limit the other limit is
what we'd really like is to be able to
tag
quite a bit more per imaging session so
we'd like a larger number of colors
let me just address the speed issue
uh quickly i mean i mentioned this
trade-off earlier
if we want to go faster we normally have
the problem that we had a lot more photo
damage
or or need to sacrifice resolution or
sacrifice step
what we've been trying to do to reach a
new balance or new compromise
is to adopt the light cheat approaches
that many others have been
using in the last few decades it's a
technique invented about a century ago
for looking at colloidal solutions
but then really reinvented a few times
over the last few decades and the most
popular one is the one that ernst
stelzer and john hooksen and their
co-workers did
where light's brought in from the side
and then the fluorescence is collected
in parallel
our version of this moves to two-photon
illumination
and we do that because for the reason
shown in the lower right
you can see the as a laser beam moves
through the screen
from right to left that as that light is
focused it gives you an almost an
hourglass shape of beads in a gel that
i'm imaging
here with 488 nanometer excitation
if instead we use two photon excitation
as we look to the left or the right
the photons aren't concentrated enough
to get an excitation
so we get a relatively thin uh light
sheet
that we can position even deep into a
specimen
and collect a a more accurate
light sheet within the specimen by
moving this excited beam
into and out of the screen for example
this has allowed us to do two photon
spin on a variety of different specimens
and i just show one here which
is a fly embryo we use them a great bit
because they're dramatically more
sensitive
to photons than most of the other
specimens we use
so we're able to see if we can image
without perturbing
by using the fly embryo and you can see
it hatched and
crawled away in fact that crawling away
happened at the same time
as it would have if they were hatching
on their own off the microscope
here's imaging within the brain of an
intact animal
we've been able to image for up to days
to be able to follow
the um the activity
in this case followed by using
g-camp 6-s a calcium
indicator that's genetically encoded you
can see the individual flashes that are
the
cells as they become active and their
calcium levels increase
so we've been really enjoying the two
photon plate sheet
it's a way to compress down the imaging
time
more than a couple orders of magnitude
and it really allows us to
jump onto the moore's law of camera
development
so that the faster better bigger
cameras that are being developed can be
used to see larger fields of view
faster and with a better sensitivity
so what about the color issue well the
color issue is one
that has haunted all of us because
almost every flora chrome that we
want to deal with has a pretty broad
emission spectrum
here i have a cartoon of a
zebrafish embryo in which the
vasculature is labeled
with egfp and the muscle cells
through which that vasculature is
running is labeled with citrine
you can see the spectra overlap a great
bit and if we look at the true color
you can't see those as two distinct
things
so what we want to be able to do is to
separate out these overlapping
fluorochromes
and also separated out from the many
other things that are there
now one temptation would be just to use
very narrow band pass filters
but as you can see even with this simple
cartoon
it would be very hard to find one narrow
band pass
that would reject one of the fluorescent
proteins and collect light from the
other one
to get around this problem
we were able to adopt the approaches
that have been developed by the remote
sensing community the people that fly
satellites and interpret their images
to collect an image cube in this case
the image cube is
x y and lambda as the third dimension
by adding a spectrometer to the confocal
microscope
one of the early adopters of this
approach under
license from caltech was the
the zeiss multispectral multi-spectral
imagers as the one shown in the lower
left
and this shows you some early prototype
results even that worked really well
even
eight spectral bands within that narrow
green region
allowed us to separate out gfp from
fluorescein even though no one of those
images does and even though the spectra
overlap tremendously
you can see here the separation out of
the
gfp from the fluorescein
they can also see one of the weak points
and if you use sort of eagle eyes you
might be able to see that
in the region of red that's the
phalloidin labeled with fitc that's been
pseudo colored red
then the region that the nucleus is the
noise and the gfp
image is being imposed on the
uh the fluorescein image so you see a
little bit of speckling there
so in dim things you're dominated by the
worst
signal to noise in the image cube and
this has
limited us to the ability to go after
multiple colors at once
luckily uh representatives from enrico
graton's lab moved
to my lab to start
doing some research and applied the
phaser approach
to this the phaser approach for those of
you that aren't familiar is to take the
fourier transform of the spectrum
so if we look here on this region of the
animal where there's only
green dyes we would get a green spectrum
as shown at the top
of the spectral plane if we looked in
places that are
only red we'd get a red spectrum and
if we take the fourier transform of the
green and the red what we can see is
that the green turns into a green dot in
the phasor plot
the phasor plot is the sine and the
cosine of
one of the harmonics of the fourier
transform series
what's the convenient about this is that
a 50 50 mix
is a dot halfway in between the two and
a 70 30 would be
[Music]
70 along the line so so basically it
takes something that
involved before inverting a matrix into
a forward problem
and this forward problem both is
dramatically faster
here i'm comparing sub trying to
separate out the signals using
optical filters trying to do linear and
mixing and finally trying to do
hyperspectral phasor
and i think what you can see is that the
bottom separation
is much better for getting a high
signal-to-noise rendering
of the vasculature and separating it
from the muscle cells
it also does it quite a bit faster so if
we just compare
then these results in a live animal
well the previous was as well but going
through
several different uh indicators in this
case
blue fluorescent protein yellow and
green and also some of the biological
uh autofluorescence the xanthophores and
the autofluorescence from metabolism and
other things
you can see that we can separate out
pretty nicely these dies that
overlap with one another tremendously
what would have been
uh hours of processing for these
multi-giga
voxel images becomes something that's
relatively fast almost as fast as you
can read the data off the hard disk
we can process it so
that solves a bit of our problem but we
still have a problem
i'm going to go back here we still have
a problem in separating these out
that these spectra are collected with a
large number of photons and we want to
be able to do the imaging at
a minimal light dose so one of our
challenges when we start doing that is
that the spectra
at low signal to noise instead of
looking like the ground
truth spectra shown in this cartoon to
the left
end up once we deal with the stochastics
of the photon emission from the
fluorescent dyes
end up being a lot messier and so
one of our challenges has been how to
use multi-spectral approaches
when the stochastics of the dye
start entering in luckily folks in the
lab have been applying machine
machine learning approaches using
the uh in this case synthetic data
ultra low signal to noise spectra uh and
comparing it to what the real spectra is
we can get a way of reconstituting the
real spectra out of it and get almost
the same data
this shows some some
[Music]
real real instead of a cartoon some real
examples of this
and then a biological example shown here
is a image of a
doubly labeled specimen imaged with very
few
photons per pixel and you can see that
the linear and mixing
um really falls apart at this point
because we're starved for photons
if instead we use the hybrid unmixing
this is using the
machine learning and the uh the
hyperspectral phaser you can see that we
get a
signal to noise that's much more
interpretable
so this approach is allowing us to look
at the things that are
most light-sensitive like growing
vasculature within an embryo
and look at multiple different labels
and also
the autofluorescence and background
noise
now this autofluorescence has a number
of different origins
and you can see that some of it is
biological like the
xanthospheres their pigment cells others
that are
things like the retinoids that are in
the tissue
and also nadh one of the
energetic intermediates that can be
either a bound or a free state depending
on if the cell
is oxidative or in uh
sorry oxfords or glycolytic
so we can use this machine learning
to sort of help us with this compromise
but uh and we can almost
you know minimize the cost of the lunch
but you know we really want to see if we
can push this further
one way to try to push it further is to
deal with the problem
that is always tempting with
multi-spectral
as we see companies coming out with
detectors that separate out the light
into not just
32 channels but even into hundreds of
channels
and while this sounds like a very good
thing what you're doing is adding
100 channels worth of noise and
splitting up the signal
into 100 different channels so you're
both decreasing the signal per channel
and
increasing the noise in the overall
thing
so one of the things we've been working
on over the years with the hyperspectral
phaser
is to see just how few channels we can
deal with
this is showing a comparison between 32
bands and
four bands and it's pretty notable how
good the four bands does even with the
simple
uh multi-labeled specimen
if we look at higher power you can see
that the
individual features can be separated out
almost as well maybe as well as they can
in the 32 band and finally if we
look at a quantitatively by scanning a
line
we can see that the signal to noise for
the four channels is
is virtually superimposable with the 32
channel
so what this is allowing us to do now is
to think about applying machine
learning and fewer channels and the
hybrid and mixing the hyperspectral
phaser tools
to try to separate things out this just
shows a little bit
of our attempts to separate out both the
intrinsic signal
and the extrinsic signal in this case
the x
extrinsic signals are the fluorescent
proteins
the intrinsic are these different
sources of autofluorescence
and you can see their position on the
hyperspectral phaser plot
and while this is encouraging there's a
problem
and the problem is that collecting the
amount of light uniformly
is is a challenge in intensity
and it's a much lower challenge in
lifetime
and so what i want to spend a little bit
of time now talking about
is our attempt to do lifetime imaging
and to combine lifetime and spectral
imaging
to get a better understanding
of overlapping labels within the same
specimen
so this hybrid around the lab we call
spectrophleum
i should mention that this sort of
emerged in the lab through a de taunt
that was uh
was created by two alumni of enrique
graton's lab
uh nemo arnisano
was a very big believer in lifetime
imaging
francesca was a very big believer in
hyperspectral imaging
and they came to bring their uh forces
together
by uh while they were at usc by
joining the two of these together just
for a moment to sort of digress into
lifetimes and some people might not be
as familiar with it
lifetime involves trying to measure the
time a flora chrome
spends in the excited state before it
drops back down to the
towards the ground state and emits a
photon
so the typical way that that can be can
be measured
is to use a pulsed laser and then
measure the time
and to add those up to obtain the the
exponential decay
that you can see in the right hand panel
so what what enrico graton and his
colleagues have shown us the amazing
power
of moving away from just doing the uh
towel curve fitting on the lifetime
curve
to moving it with the phaser approach
into the for a transformer phasor space
you can see the different lifetimes now
appear at different places on the phasor
plot
and if we think about the hyperspectral
responses of those exogenous and
endogenous
uh labels you can see that they show up
at characteristic places neither one of
them
is really perfect but both of them are
extremely informative and so we've been
involved in trying to work with vendors
and with some of our own uh soldering
irons and such to build instrumentation
that can really collect the spectra
and the lifetime and been for example in
one experiment
uh shooting that down a bronchoscope so
that we can see the response
of the airways in both
hyperspectral and lifetime imaging
the lifetime imaging is very convenient
for looking at the
metabolic profile the nadh signal
when it's freeze is it rough represents
the more
oxidative phosphorylation sort of
um sort of response of the cells
the glycolytic is when the
nadh is is
free and you can see in this color-coded
image of individual cells in the airway
that we can tell the difference on a
cell by cell basis
if we look at hyperspectral you can see
some things that we're just blind to in
the lifetime
like the autofluorescence from the
elastin and collagen that's shown in
green
to the left of the hyperspectral image
and you can imagine that combining the
two is going to be
the most informative and we're trying to
do that now to
generate something that could be used in
the very noisy environment
of imaging human airways
also been extending this to looking at
organoids
and really trying to see how far we can
push these different modalities and this
is a picture from a paper that
nemo generated now a couple years ago
combining together everything from
lifetime imaging to hyperspectral
imaging
and then techniques like phase contrast
and oct
as well so what we've been trying to do
is come up with instrumentation to
combine
all of these and the challenge has been
to make them robust
we've been lucky as we've started to
look
carry this just fewer and fewer cells
that the the leica fortune
and falcon approach has allowed us to
do this much more conveniently so the
four tune gives us four different
uh spectral bands i've shown you earlier
that four bands
is enough to get very nice hyperspectral
results out of it
and that's allowed us to do things like
image over a days long
period as a group of cells that were
isolated at zero hours all because they
were stem cells
it turns out that the yellow rev
reflects the metabolic state that's
indicative of the stem cells
you can see if the four cells were
following that
three of them are still a little bit in
that stem cell state
one's come really quite a bit out of it
um
a better part of a day later 20 hours
into the recording you can see that
there's only one of them and then at the
end you can see that basically all of
them have
given up on the stem cell-like
metabolism
we're now using this in culture plates
and organoids and in intact systems
to try to eavesdrop on the biology of
of the cells and the physiology of the
cells and while it's early days uh
working with the falcon has been really
powerful for getting both the spectral
and the lifetime data out
so i'm going to stop here because i
think that you know i could go on and on
about our
children and the way we're trying to use
them in the lab our children being our
different techniques and our different
instruments
what i've tried to share with you today
is our approach to try to add dimensions
to the imaging
i showed you a little bit about our
multiplex imaging
and both the abilities and challenges
there
i showed you a little bit about the
spectral phasor analysis
and showed you our ability to separate
out multiple labels
even if we're only looking at four
spectral bands
and then at the end i showed you the
ability to use lifetime
and spectra instead of doing
spectrophyllin imaging
and this brings up the power of jointly
refining instrumentation
it's turned out to be much easier for us
to support
users by having integrated
instrumentation that can do
both the spectral data collection and
the lifetime
data it allows us to jointly define
what the optimal signal the noise is
like the number of channels that's
really appropriate
and one of the things that we're finding
is we're doing this joint development
of instrumentation that can do lifetime
and spectra
is that less might really be more and
we're still
trying to find the right compromise but
it might really be
that as few as four spectral bands is
enough
to give us the best low light level
performance and also very usable
uh label separation
so i'm going to end by thanking the
people that really made these
technologies possible
the multiplex in c2 drew on a
collaboration
with niles pierce and his colleagues at
caltech when we were there
laytran and vikas trevetti were the real
driving forces on moving that
collaboration forward and then in the
further refinement of
the technology that i mentioned is muse
is really simon and joe that drove that
forward
the hyperspectral phaser really owes
its creation to francesco true trolley
and all of his colleagues
who've been working on different aspects
of improving the performance
and the speed and
of the hyperspectral phaser approaches
and integrating them
in with lifetime tools as well
the two photon spins really been driven
by tai
and his colleagues and i've listed a few
of them here but of course
in any one of these lists there's always
more that we could list
and finally the spectrophone has really
been something that has involved
many labs and as we've started to show
the technologies
we've found people in ophthalmology and
cancer biology
and beta cell biology and a variety of
other
systems these collaborating labs shown
at the bottom
that are working together with the
people in our lab to really refine
together these spectrophony sort of
techniques
and i think i'll stop there and see if
there's any questions and
hopefully you've enjoyed what i've
shared with you today
thank you dr fraser for your informative
presentation
and we want to thank our audience for
their interesting questions
all questions that come in today and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be answered by dr fraser via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
fraser for his time today
and his important research we would also
like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
that's all for now until next time
goodbye